Ellen master thank you so much for
joining me today thanks for having me I
am gonna show the book here because this
I find this is just a great book I
enjoyed this thoroughly thank you so
much for saying that what a lot of
people may not realize is if they've
watched that old black and white movie
about time travel where the guy has to
drag the time machine because he goes
back in time but time has changed he
ends up where he doesn't want to be
inside a building somewhere in the past
that in fact is is not the way it works
and I really never thought about it
until I read your book but if we went
back just a few seconds to the beginning
of when I started this interview we
wouldn't be here we wouldn't be in some
place ten seconds ago where would we be
well yeah that's one of the things I had
fun exploring the book is that we feel
like we're stationary right now we're
sitting here doing this interview but
we're actually moving in incredible
speeds we know that the earth is
spinning at the equator at about a
thousand miles an hour it's rotating
around the Sun at about 67,000 miles an
hour the Sun is moving through the
galaxy at 1.3 million miles an hour so
right now if we were to go back to
seconds we would be about half a
kilometer away and so I like the idea of
exploring among many things in the book
that when you travel back in time you
also have to travel back in space
because if you were to go back to
yesterday the earth would be thousands
and thousands of kilometres away we
might end up somewhere in the middle of
space so you would I mean you know right
where we're sitting right now wouldn't
be in the same place we would be out in
the empty vacuum of space and so unless
you have a model of time travel that
also considers not just that the earth
is spinning incredibly quickly but it's
moving at unbelievable speeds you go
back you know 30 years like Marty McFly
did in Back to the Future you don't end
up landing in the exact same spot where
you took off you end up floating in the
vacuum of space with the earth a million
minus millions and millions of miles
away yeah and so that is one of many
sort of fun sort of ways of looking at
the genre in with fresh eyes you know
try to come up with a model of time
travel it isn't just walking through a
door but one that actually factors in
orbital mechanics
right where'd you get the idea for a
book on time travel well
I when I was growing out my grandfather
who was a chemist I grew up in Vancouver
he had this extensive collection of old
vintage science fiction from the 50s and
60s
Bradbury Heinlein Asimov Banach yet all
the kind of classics and I just loved
them and I'm not just the sort of wild
and vivid stories inside them but also I
just love the covers you know what these
garishly painted images of you know sign
that scientists and robots and
futuristic cityscapes rocket ships and
exactly you know and I'm but even as a
kid in the 80s I knew that the future
wasn't turning out exactly the way these
writers and artists imagined you know
yeah I I did not get a jetpack for my
12th birthday you know that seemed like
a terrible crime but don't have Jetsons
flying cars either we don't and the
other thing that happened to me when I
in 86 in Vancouver Expo 86 was hosted I
know it was a World's Fair like you know
all the great World's Fairs like
Montreal 67 and Expo and the World's
Fair in New York in 64 and I was dazzled
by and it captured my imagination I
spent a ton of time on the expo grounds
it's only recently that I would look
back on it and did a little bit of
research and realized Expo 86 was
actually the last World's Fair we ever
hosted in North America in fact we
stopped posting them here it's like we
stopped dreaming of that future but I
always was always thought about that
question what happened to the future we
imagined was going to happen what went
wrong why are we here in 2016 it's very
different than the one that are that
your post-war generation imagined and so
that that that thought was the genesis
of this book and then I kind of went
from there the whole idea of course is
if you go and and this remains a big
question for anybody who thinks about
this is if you go and back into the past
even it's kind of like the butterfly
effect that's right yeah
even a minor detail can vastly change
changes in the future right and in my
book when the character goes back it he
doesn't cause a minor change he causes a
massive change and and he wakes he ends
up in a very different version of the
world but one of the twists of the book
is that a very different version of the
world that he wakes up in is our world
the book is no big when the book opens
it's in the present but it's in this
of the present that the post-war
generation imagined the sort of techno
utopian fantasy flying cars and robot
maids and hotels on the moon
teleportation but with there's a you
know a terrible mistake with a prototype
time machine and my protagonist causes
this accident in 1965 and when he
returns to the present he wakes up an
hour version of the world what we
perceived to be the real world but for
him is this terrible dystopia where
everything has gone wrong what happened
to our flying cars what happened to our
jetpacks so of course he wants to get
back to his version of the world but
along the way he discovers these very
unexpected versions of the people in his
life his family this woman he has this
romantic connection with and even
himself he's a very different person and
I like the idea of looking at the world
around us with fresh eyes bringing
somebody from a much more sophisticated
I mean technologically sophisticated not
necessarily sophisticated in all ways
but a technologically advanced version
of the world and dropping him into our
world and having a look around and said
what happened you make it very
interesting as well by using some actual
technological facts yeah how much
research did you have to do to get these
things are quite a bit um you know the I
mentioned my grandfather as a scientist
you know one of his kind of gripes about
the science fiction genre is that you
know you have all these great stories
they use all these ideas but they never
actually took the time to get the
science right and if they would just get
the science right he would say to me
this the stories would actually be more
interesting because the science is
fascinating and so when I set out to
write this book I you know because the
inspiration came from my grandfather I
wanted to honor that imperative as well
so yeah I mean I don't put all of my
research in the book like I didn't want
a situation where the reader has to wade
through pages and pages of scientific
research obviously this is a novel it's
a story first but I liked working a lot
of real scientific details technological
details in there because I just feel
like it grounds of the story makes it
more textured or more authentic
mmm in the end the cover it you if maybe
people don't notice this right away but
you have the skyline of Toronto yeah and
then upside down you have the sky later
Toronto so is it is a case of a lot of
people wonder whether there are
alternate or alternative realities
but you're saying this is sort of like
it could go this way or that way yeah
yeah I mean I'm very interested like a
lot of people in the what ifs of life
what you know what a decision you could
have made at some point in your life
that was kind of like a hinge that
changed the trajectory of your life but
I also think because of my personal
family history I think a lot about how
who we are ends up being the result of
historical forces that are far beyond
our own small lives you know and many of
my grandfather grew up in the great
depression and that profoundly
influenced the trajectory of his life
my grandmother had grew up in Vienna and
had to escape the Nazis in the war and
ended up in North America my father as
well as a child he was born in Morocco
and ended up having to escape from from
World War two into France and then his
by the time he was 10 years old he had
lived on three different continents he
was in Israel and I think a lot about
you know when I was growing up around
the dinner table everybody had a
different accent I was born in Vancouver
but I was a first generation Canadian
and just thinking about how the effects
of these giant sweeps of history Wars
and cultural revolutions and depressions
and how all these things which you read
in history books actually profoundly
influenced how I was even born of all
the people in my life conference of
history yeah and so I want to think
about that too it's not just our own
personal choices although those of
course can have profound impact but also
how a different hinge in history could
lead you to have a very different life I
must congratulate you as well Ellen must
I on the fact that you set this in
Toronto as a Canadian writer you set
this in a sort of a Canadian although
this guy travels around quite a bit yeah
I mean is there any pressure I mean to
make this more marketable by not setting
it in Canada and setting it somewhere
else
no I never I never had got that kind of
kind of pressure I mean the majority of
the story probably about 60% if it takes
place in Toronto some of it takes place
in San Francisco in Hong Kong because
his journey kind of takes him around
around the world but no it's very
proudly and specifically said in in
Toronto which is where I live right now
as a Canadian writer I just wanted to
first of all write about the place I
live my perspective is Canadian I'm
Canadian I've lived here my whole life
but also I feel like you know we're at
this point I think people are proud to
be Canadian our literature is very
mature
we have terrific writers that whose work
travels all around the world and I don't
think there's any reason to kind of like
sheepishly pretend that it's we're not
who we are I'm proud of what Canada
represents right now in the world and
even though we're a tad if slightly
different geopolitical situation than we
were when I finished the book this
summer I feel like I just wanted to
write a book um that was you know it's
there's time travel and alternate
realities and all kinds of big plot
twists and turns and characters revealed
but it's still a story that is written
by Canadian in the set here because
that's who I am
now we've been talking a lot about time
travel but this isn't necessarily a book
about time travel is it time travel is a
plot device that I used to it's really
more about alternate realities and the
consequences of our choices sometimes
understand abilities yeah and the
responsibilities we have you know I mean
a big concept I talk about in the book
is the study of the accident that the
sense that anytime you introduce a
technology you also reduce the accident
of that technology there's no such thing
as a car crash until you invent the car
there's no such thing as a plane crash
until you invent the plane and so and I
like to explore the unintended
consequences of things so both
technology but also people how you meet
somebody new
and they can have all these unintended
consequences in your life and vice versa
and so yeah to me this is really a story
about people and how once you pull all
the technology away although obviously
that stuff is fun to write about what
what you're left with is the connections
between them and how the people that we
meet the people we choose to love the
family we grew up in that's what really
gives our life meaning and that's what
fundamentally changes the trajectory of
our lives rather than messed I I must
say it was a truly fascinating book and
so I thank you very much for this
congratulations thank you and thank you
for having me on your show